bé của bà sẽ ngủ
tì tì suốt cả đêm nếu như các bà áp dụng các quy tắc và các mẹo sau đây
ngay cả khi em bé nằm điều hòa còn nhỏ xíu đỏ họt
vẫn có thể nằm được và ngủ rất là ngon tới sáng nha
đầu tiên là quy tắc 2 ngón Tay
đừng bao giờ đoán định cái thân nhiệt của em bé bằng cái việc là sờ
Tay hay là sờ chân
bởi vì Tay chân nó là ở ngoại VI ấy đôi khi ấy nó
Tay chân nó mát nhưng mà em bé nó chưa chắc là nó lạnh đâu nha
mình sẽ phải sờ vào gáy
dùng 2 ngón Tay mà sờ vào gáy của em bé thấy gáy của em bé nóng và ẩm
Tay của em bé thì có
thể là đang nóng thì có nghĩa là em bé mình đang nóng nha các bà cần phải hạ
nhiệt độ phòng xuống bởi vì nóng quá em bé không thể ngủ ngon được đâu
nếu như mà sờ vào gáy của em bé
mà thấy gáy mát lạnh và Tay chân cũng mát lạnh luôn lạnh hẳn ấy
thì có nghĩa là em bé nó đang hơi lạnh
các bà cần phải hạ nhiệt độ xuống hoặc là mặc thêm quần áo Cho em bé
hoặc là đắp chăn gì đó
thế rồi nếu như mà mình sờ vào gáy của em bé
mà thấy gáy của em bé ấm nhưng mà khô khô ráo
Tay chân của em bé có thể ấm
đó có nghĩa là đây là nhiệt độ rất phù hợp đối với em bé
em bé nó rất là thích với cái nhiệt độ này
đấy là quy tắc 2 ngón Tay thế rồi bây giờ đến quy tắc BA phút
trước khi mà Ra khỏi phòng ấy thì mình sẽ
điều hòa là một sáng sớm dậy mình tắt điều hòa là mình Ra khỏi phòng đúng không
mình sẽ Cho em bé nó đứng ở chỗ cái cửa
để Cho cái lúc mà không khí nó đối lưu nó lưu thông ấy
à nó sẽ giao thoa giữa 2 cái loại nhiệt độ để Cho em bé nó không bị sốc nhiệt
đấy là Ra khỏi phòng cũng thế đứng đấy BA phút
lúc mà mới bước vào phòng cũng như vậy nha
đừng bao giờ mà đang ngoài trời nắng sồng sộc sồng sộc chạy vào
trong phòng đưa Cho em bé vào trong phòng để Cho em bé mát
nhất là lúc mà nó vừa mới chơi xong mồ hôi mồ kê
mà đi vào phòng luôn rất là dễ bị sốc nhiệt
người lớn mình cũng rất là dễ bị sốc nhiệt
cái kiểu như là mình đang ở ngoài trời nóng xong mình bước vào xe ô
tô mà điều hòa lạnh toát ấy
mẹo để giúp Cho em bé ngủ ngon
đầu tiên đấy là các bà lúc nào cũng để một cái cốc nước ở trong phòng của mình
lúc mà các bạn đang đêm các bà ngủ dậy đi tè ấy
xong vào nhấc một chút nước
nhấc một chút thôi đừng nhiều quá xong nó làm Cho mình đi tè nhiều
nó sẽ làm Cho cái cổ họng của mình được cấp ẩm và nó đỡ bị khô
sáng dậy nó sẽ đỡ bị ngứa họng và làm Cho mình kiểu bị ho Khan đấy
thì nó sẽ đỡ đi rất nhiều nha
thứ 2 đấy là cái mũi của em bé và mũi của mình
đang đêm mà thấy cái mũi nó khô khô nghĩa là chắc chắn mũi con sẽ khô
dậy xịt nước muối ưu nhược trương nhược chương
xịt mình một cái xịt con một cái
trong này nó là nước muối nhược chương hàm lượng muối
thấp hơn 0,9%
và nó có cái thành phần cấp ẩm và khóa ẩm axit
nó sẽ giúp Cho cái niêm mạc mũi của em bé nó được cấp
ẩm lại bình thường tại SAO nằm điều hòa nó lại làm Cho mình dễ bị ốm
dễ bị viêm hô hấp là bởi vì SAO bình
thường cái mũi mình lúc nào nó cũng có một cái lớp thảm nhầy
thảm dịch nhầy
nó sẽ giúp bắt giữ VI khuẩn vào khi mà mình hít vào ấy
cái VI khuẩn VI nấm bụi bẩn
VI rút nó sẽ được bám giữ ở cái lớp nhầy đấy
không Cho đi sâu vào nhân mặc đồ hấp bên trong
thế nhưng mà khi mà nằm điều hoàn hút hết ẩm
không khí nó rất là khô và niêm mạc mũi của mình cũng thế rất khô nha
nó sẽ làm Cho mình dễ bị viêm đường hô hấp
bây giờ mình sẽ ờ ừm khắc phục bằng cái cách là mình sẽ cấp ẩm
cái niêm mạc mũi hạng của mình bằng nước muối nhược
Trương bằng cái cách bằng uống nước
nha
trước khi đi ngủ thì sẽ xịt nước muối nhược trương để Cho đỡ khô và khóa ẩm lại
đang đêm mà thấy cái mũi khó chịu cũng dậy xịt
sáng sớm dậy thấy
ờm cũng xịt nha đấy
ở đây là cái nước muối nhược trương các bà có
thể dùng nước muối sinh lý cũng được nhưng nó cấp
ẩm không tốt bằng cái nhược trương này
thế rồi à một cái mẹo nữa là các bà sẽ dùng cái máy cấp ẩm
cái máy để tạo ẩm trong không khí ấy
nếu như mà không có máy thì các bạn có thể làm giống như tôi đây
đây là một cái chậu nước đấy xong cái tôi để cái khăn như này
để Cho nó hút
hút nước lên xong rồi nó sẽ tạo cái hơi ẩm ở trong cái không khí của mình
đấy lúc nào ở trong cái phòng nó cũng sẽ có cái Châu nước như này để các
một cái điều ít bà biết đấy là điều hòa của mình nó có cái chế độ ngủ
à nó có cái chữ sleep đây này
hoặc là một số cái điều hòa nó sẽ có cái biểu hiện bằng cái a cái
cái nửa mặt trăng ấy cái mặt mặt trăng khuyết ấy
cái chế độ ngủ này nó sẽ Cho phép mình là cái điều hòa nó sẽ hoạt động là
sau khi mà mình ngủ
bình thường mình mới vào phòng mình sẽ bật chế độ cool hoặc là auto
để Cho cái phòng nó lạnh
đấy nhiệt độ phù hợp đối với em bé nó sẽ khoảng là 25 đến 26 độ
ờ tùy vào cái điều hòa nha một số những cái điều hòa mới thì nó lạnh rất là sâu
còn một số cái điều hòa thì nó cùi quá thì các bà sẽ phải ừm
cảm nhận bằng cái cơ thể của mình hoặc là nếu mà các bà cẩn
thận các bà có thể mua cái máy
để kiểm soát xem nhiệt độ là bao nhiêu đấy ờ
nằm ở phòng lúc nào mình cảm thấy hơi se se lạnh
thì có nghĩa là em bé mình đang cảm thấy dễ chịu
à xong rồi sờ vào gáy nó cảm thấy gáy nó ấm khô và Tay chân nó cũng hơi ấm ấm
hoặc là hơi mát mát thì em bé nó đang dễ chịu nha
đấy các bà bật cái nhiệt độ à bật cái chế độ slip này
cái chế độ slip này nó sẽ làm Cho
sau khi mà mình à
tức là khi mà bắt đầu ngủ ấy thì bật cái clip này
sau khoảng một thời gian thì nó sẽ tăng cái nhiệt độ lên
à bởi vì lúc mà mình đi ngủ cái thân nhiệt của mình nó sẽ bị giảm xuống mà
và ban đêm cái nhiệt độ nó cũng giảm đi nha
vì thế nên là khi mình bật cái slip này cái nhiệt độ nó tăng lên
ví dụ lúc đầu các bà bật là 2 tư độ sau khi đấy
sau khi mà bắt đầu ngủ các bà bật vào cái chiếc slip này
thì nó sẽ lên là 26 độ
cái quạt gió nó cũng sẽ nhẹ hơn và cái máy nó sẽ chạy êm hơn nha đấy
một cái điều rất quan
trọng đấy là các bà không bao giờ để Cho cái luồng gió của cái điều hòa nó phả
thẳng vào đầu hay là mặt hay là cổ của con mình hay là gáy nhá
nó nó nó rất là dễ làm Cho em bé bị cảm rồi hắt hơi sổ mũi đấy